so you've just heard why our nominees
for animated shorts fell in love with
animation
me i fell in love with animated movies
when my mother took me to a movie
theater for the very first time to see
the animated movie called
the secret of nim i remember vividly the
lead character was mrs brisby
and she was a fierce mother mouse
determined to protect her children from
a dangerous farmer's plow
it was my first experience in seeing a
strong woman at the center of a film
and that is the power of really great
animation
it shows you as a child that anything is
possible
that you can change the world even if
you're small as a mouse
tonight we have nominees here with us in
person
but we want to say a special hello to
those joining us from london
and kilkenny ireland
here are the nominees for best animated
feature
onward dan scanlon and corey ray over
the moon
glenn keane jenny rim and palin chow
a sean the sheep movie farmageddon
richard phelan
will beecher and paul kuley seoul
pete doctor and dana murray wolf walkers
tom moore ross stewart paul young and
stefan rollins
and the oscar for best animated feature
goes to
[Applause]
seoul
[Music]
wow uh okay i've been nominated
nominated to
speak on behalf of dana and kemp powers
our co-director
this film started as a love letter to
jazz
but we had no idea how much jazz would
teach us about life
like we don't get to control what
happens but we can
like a jazz musician turn whatever
happens into something of value and
something of beauty
and that was certainly true of our
amazing cast jamie foxx tina fey
you guys are amazing uh our brilliant
collaborators trent rezner and atticus
ross
john batiste this guy over there
it was just fantastic working with all
you guys uh
uh our cultural consultants uh dr
genetic coal
uh people who helped kept us honest and
keep those characters truthful
we're really thankful to our partners at
disney who
when we said hey we want to do a film
that explores the
purpose of life they're like okay go
ahead
that's not your usual cartoon fair
and of course to our family
dana wants to thank my amazing husband
my parents i'm here because of you i
love you so much
hazel and murray my baby's at home
you're everything to me
um we obviously have to think that the
crew who made this film and even
finished it from home
with seven weeks of production left you
are
you're you should be up here with us and
we are just the lucky speakers
i'm not supposed to be speaking actually
so our main character joe is a music
teacher uh we want to thank music
teachers and art teachers everywhere you
including my parents dave and rita and
dana's parents
pam and tom you make the world a better
place and my my wish for all of us
tonight
is that we could follow the example of
jazz musicians that
wherever we are whatever we have we turn
it into something beautiful
thank you
you